[Musique]
pourquoi panorama pernois ramon a déjà
le titre
c'est une proposition à cesser de
présenter un panorama de la création
actuelle et contemporaine sur notre
territoire
on est dans les arts plastiques on
présente sur la production de quatre
soutiens et plasticienne qui viennent de
tous horizons qui ont des pratiques
diverses et multiples qui ont aussi des
parcours et des niveaux de performance
qu'on a des approches assez différent
des styles des choses très contemporaine
ya des choses très engagé mais il ya
aussi des paysages ya moyen vraiment de
réfléchir et surtout ça peut inciter les
gens qui s'intéressent plus à un style
qu'à un autre de pouvoir apprécier
l'écriture de nouveaux artistes de
débutants ou en même temps de
d'artistes de confirmer ce travail et
d'exposition ne s'arrête pas là parce
qu'on propose aussi de la médiation en
direction du public scolaire et aussi en
direction du grand public
donc on est très heureux dans cette
période de crise sanitaire d'avoir fait
le maximum à tous les niveaux pour que
la culture les acteurs culturels soient
accueillis et soutenus par le
département la veille
[Musique]